[Music]
i'm on a
binge right now to try to educate a lot
of people that the soft skills are
actually the hard skills i know you
don't love talking about yourself that
way but you can help a lot of people
right now which one over indexed or you
think was foundational or which couple
really mattered during this chapter
[Music]
the garyvee audio
experience hey everybody it's gary
vaynerchuk super excited to uh be back
here on the podcast 2021 has been
a journey on original content on the
podcast and that journey continues today
in very exciting form for me personally
and for i'm sure many of the listeners
of this podcast because today we have
what is easily described especially for
my generation as one of the
entrepreneurs
that
many of us looked up to were aware of
put some real wins on the board as a
young man has continued in
uh
that journey and is now
writing a book that i'm excited to talk
about and i'm excited to
hopefully dig into some stuff that
hasn't been touched on before because
i'm going to go very improv like i tend
to do
but
unlike
many of the guests that come through i
always say some of you might not be
aware
this one i have a funny feeling almost
all of you are aware the the iconic
michael dallas here michael it is a real
pleasure thank you for being on the show
yeah thank you very much gary great to
be with you thank you my friend for that
one person
that isn't i always like to do comic
book number one right episode one
give me two three minutes on context on
even maybe how you see yourself how do
you talk you know
hey who are you nice to meet you what do
you think like tell me a little bit
about yourself so
why don't you give a little uh
two-minute bio
not something i do a lot but uh yeah so
i started a technology company uh in my
dorm room when i was 19 at the
university of texas
and today we're a little over 100
billion dollar business
operating in 180 countries and we're the
leading provider of
cloud infrastructure and
you know
technology capabilities to enable
companies to
drive their digital transformation
take me back a little bit further before
we get into the book
what was the seed
do you have a sense of like
what was the moment or the three or four
building blocks that got you to
starting the company or the journey
sure so
i was um
really fortunate you know in junior high
school to get access to a teletype
terminal this is before
the pc i learned about byte magazine and
was reading about the dawn of the
microprocessor age and
you know radio shack for a brief moment
in time made more pcs than anybody and
then you know apple came out with the
apple ii and i
had saved up enough money from
entrepreneurial ventures to get one of
those and and what were those
entrepreneurial ventures
oh it was uh you know
baseball cards uh stamp auction
uh stock trading
all kinds of very very but it's funny
all three of those very trading oriented
no
if you think about it stamps baseball
cards and stocks all kind of buy
sell for more very much also by the way
my dna though i had a little more
lemonade car washing shoveling snow in
the mix there but it was interesting
i love entrepreneurship so much i'm
always curious
all three of those
and for everybody who's listening
stamps
were no question
the baseball cards of that generation
prior
probably a generation or two above
michael and definitely above me as well
um interesting that all three of those
fall under the same in my opinion from
my perspective realm of buy it for
something sell it for more
yeah i you know
got a job working in a chinese
restaurant when i was 12. i was a
dishwasher
uh got promoted to waterboy and then
made her d uh got recruited away to a
mexican restaurant and michael do you
think you had lots of jobs michael do
you think you learned a lot about
consumer by being on the trenches of
restaurants
yeah
you you certainly learn how to
uh be empathetic and to serve and to
uh listen carefully and you know you
want to please right and you want to do
well and so
you know you learn how to relate to lots
of different kinds of people and figure
out what is the best path and the best
strategy to to make that happen
i agree with that so
you know the apple ii comes along i i uh
get one of those take it apart
uh
1981
ibm introduces the ibm pc and
you know most people maybe don't uh
remember this or weren't alive then but
uh you know during the 1980s
ibm was
the most valuable company uh in the
world and
you know was
uh completely dominant in the field of
data processing which you know sort of
has become what we think of as
technology and so when they introduced
the ibm pc
uh
you know i got involved in that took
that apart started upgrading them i was
helping
my
friends learn how to program and
you know uh started
upgrading computers for my friend's
parents and
that turned into a little bit of a
business
went off to college michael were you
known so right so this sounds like this
is high school were you known
as as like a whiz kid because you
understood this new computer thing
because of that
yeah pretty much yeah yeah makes sense i
was i was pretty pretty geeky
yep and um oh i forgot i also uh had a
job at um
at a newspaper and figured out how to
sell more subscriptions than anybody had
ever sold before and made a bunch of
money doing that
and uh how did you do that by the way
so uh i figured out that
people that were buying the newspaper
uh
several things about them but one
very distinctive one was that they were
often getting married and it turns out
that when you get married in texas as in
many states you have to get a marriage
license and that is available under the
freedom information act so
you could go to the county courthouse
and request all the marriage licenses
and on the license
uh the the the couple filled out
they listed the address
that they wanted the license to be sent
to
and so i created a direct mail campaign
uh made you know about eighteen thousand
dollars doing that which you know back
in uh in the early eighties was was it a
trillion dollar i mean when i was making
yeah when i hear that i'm like oh i know
exactly what that is because when i was
making seven hundred dollars
you know a weekend selling baseball
cards in 1990 or 1989 it was like a
billion i mean numbers were just
different and when you're a kid
everything's compounded so that was
massive i also love the fact that you're
already getting into
smart data you know i a lot of my
success in social media marketing comes
from the fact that i did a ton of direct
mail
from my dad's wine store and i was very
good quote unquote at it and you can
transfer those skills
yeah so i got into direct mail at the
age of 16 uh with a massive direct mail
campaign
for the houston post newspaper and
uh you know when i went off to college
i really kind of ramped up the the
business of upgrading computers
talk about all this in the book my
parents got really upset with me
kind of uh you know
one point was sitting there watching my
mom cry and
you know because she thought that you
were getting distracted from studies
which would undermine your future
oh yeah for sure yeah it makes sense and
uh and so
there was a 10-day period where i
completely stopped and it was during
those 10 days that i really decided that
this was something more than a a fun way
to make money and a house because in
those 10 days you were so unhappy
because it wasn't a part of your life
that you knew this was different
yeah and i and i just felt the
opportunity was too compelling so
michael on that note i apologize because
i'm being very selfish for my audience
and i think this is an incredible
opportunity for them sure no worries
michael please explain to this audience
that there's a by the way this you know
i i have a nice young base but there is
an ungodly amount of 45 to 90 year olds
listening right now but
for the ones that aren't 45 to 90
please explain
how different entrepreneurship was
positioned i mean you were a step
you know ahead of me you know for me it
was 1990 was high school entry in 1994
was college entry and like
i was
unbelievably
productive as an entrepreneur but my my
poor grades
i don't know i think you might have been
a better student than me but my poor
grades were
most people thought i was going to be
not successful because entrepreneurship
almost had no
place at the table for profession
i'm gonna have to assume
and i just want everybody to hear from
you because i think now everybody's a
creator or an entrepreneur or aspires to
be one so the culture shifted explain to
everybody like what the positioning was
from having a business on the side at
school like it was very unique no
yeah it was it was definitely unique uh
i you know very very i didn't really
don't know anybody else that was doing
it and interestingly enough you know it
was the dawn of the
the pc age and none of the students were
even interested in personal computers
i was selling to
you know small businesses and doctors
and lawyers and you know uh you know
universities in the area the the those
were my customers but yes i didn't
really think of it as i'm gonna have a
career as an entrepreneur
i just saw an opportunity
and
was off to go
you know and executed
build a business and and uh it had
gotten to about eighty thousand dollars
a month uh in my dorm room and
i thought uh what year was that michael
it was uh you know
1983 1984 is when i incorporated the
company two weeks before i finished my
final exams with my freshman year
so michael in
83-84
you're doing a million dollar run rate
selling something that most people
outside of a geeky culture or
professional culture
didn't even have demand for
again for everybody's listening money's
gotten weird
back then that number is staggering i i
can't even like i forget about inflation
to put into context if you find a kid
like a charlie demilio that's making 30
50 million a year being an influencer
like i have to assume that when you
would tell your most inner family or
friends
about where the run rate was it was
almost difficult for people to believe
it to be true no
well it wasn't i wasn't my style to go
around telling people which is why i
said inner circle right i'm sure i even
know your style now so i assumed back
then even but somebody had to hear it
right a cousin a best friend like who
whether it was three people or 30 people
i have to assume they were astonished at
the scale that this could be no yeah
yeah for sure and you know the first
nine months uh
that i started from may of 84 we had
um
six million dollars in revenue and then
the first full year was 33 million
we grew
80 percent compounded for eight years in
a row
and then for six years after that we
grew
uh sixty percent compounded so if you do
the math on that you get well over ten
billion dollars which is exactly what
happened and so uh you know the business
uh
got off to a fast start
was it called was it called dell from
the beginning
it was incorporated as dell computer
corporation our trading name for the
first few years was pcs limited and
there's a there's a fun story in the
book about exactly how that happened it
was it was uh
kind of a lawyer who named the company
you said a lawyer named it which i love
given the name that you told me just now
it sounds exactly like a lawyer did that
branding work when did you switch it to
dell
so so the actually the lawyer named the
company dell computer corporation
for the legal term because last name got
it and then you named it from a
front-facing brand standpoint
it i i had
i've been a
uh you know kind of sole proprietor uh
before and i had named the company pcs
limited
because you wanted it you wanted to seem
bigger on the name more broad
you know
who the heck knows i mean we were
focused on pcs and we were pcs limited
so
so that that was the name you know kind
of starting in the in the uh beginning
of 1984.
then we incorporated it as dell computer
corporation
fast forward to about 1987
and we started our global expansion
uh in in the uk
and uh
we hire a team over there and they're
getting going
and
you know they're like well we can't be
pcs limited limited because that doesn't
make any sense you know what should we
call the company and you know we were so
busy uh growing so fast back in austin
we're like we don't know you just just
figured you just name it
and so so the guys in the uk decided
well the
actual name of the company is still
computer corporation so that's what
we're going to call it in the uk wow so
there was a period of time there and
then
uh i was kind of reluctant but the team
ultimately convinced me to
you you you were more
relying on your humility and just kind
of like you thought it might be
audacious to name it after yourself
that's why you were holding off a little
bit
well i you know thought about the
osborne effect uh you know um
adam osborne you know uh
you know introduced a new machine it it
failed and you know he it kind of
became memorialized as the osborne
effect and yep you know i certainly uh
didn't want that to happen they didn't
want that to happen and you know when
when
so
let's go let's let's segue because i
know we don't have a lot of time and i
appreciate how busy you are and i want
to get some stuff on the book
what's the book about for those curious
because i want everybody to pick it up
and get them value and number two
why do you think you wrote it now
because there's a whole lot of times i
assume you could have wrote it in the
past and maybe even in the future since
you're still a young man what break that
down for me
well the book really starts out at the
moment that i am
trying to
uh take the company private and
really reignite ex explain that to
everybody even in the macro context
because i know that might not be
something everyone knows right so the
company goes public in in 1988 issue
shares to shareholders
was that was that an insane moment for
you
yeah it was pretty fun i was 23 years
old a public company and uh
you know it was kind of the only way you
could access the capital markets to grow
their you know uh the
venture wasn't available to us there
were no space back in 1998
and
all these ways to fund today the jobs
act all these different things vcs
private all of it non-existent the only
way to get real cash to go real crazy
which is clearly your ambition at that
time
was to go public
yeah exactly so fast forward 25 years
the stock had appreciated
thirteen thousand five hundred percent
that's uh 27 times more than the s p 500
during that time but market wasn't
giving us permission to
really transform and
we'd been investing in all sorts of new
areas in cloud and security and software
but kind of the more we did it the less
the market liked it they were infatuated
with smartphones yep and uh thought that
you know hey smartphones are here
so the pc is is gone dead
people michael why do you think there's
an obsession and i listen i throw around
the term i've really tried to not more
because it's just not true when there's
a new thing
that will absolutely take market share
this obsession with
then taking whatever is the incumbent
and just calling it dead when in reality
looking at innovation over the last 100
years
it's far more
dented
sliced for a little bit
you know you know and why why do you
think there's such an obsession of like
oh this is here now well this is all
dead instead of no no this is gonna take
some market share
do i believe that the social media
stream has taken market share from
television commercials i sure do but
it's not officially dead there are still
television commercials in 2022 why do
you think that is in our society
well first of all news flash uh last
quarter we shipped more computers than
ever before and i love that i love that
so you know if it's dead it's it's
giving a really good impression of being
being alive
uh but well that's that's the question
so that news to that news flash that's
my point right like like here we are all
these years later after smartphone and
people what people don't realize is that
markets expand and people have three
devices not one right it's an and thing
not an ore thing and that's kind of what
we thought then and look i mean
uh just because it's conventional wisdom
and everybody else is doing it and
believes that it's right
doesn't mean that it's completely right
and if you find those opportunities that
others don't see
uh there can be just tremendous
opportunity and and so
that's what you saw and that's where
this book catches up like hey
the market's telling me you stink you're
the you're in the past i see that it's
going to be and not or which is
brilliantly said i say it all the time
let me
do something about this and take it back
private and
take back my company in essence right
right and and you know when you do that
you put the company up for sale
basically because anybody can buy it you
know if somebody wanted to pay a penny
more than i and silverlake were willing
to pay they they could have done that
and so it was an epic battle uh carl
icahn showed up and was sort of the the
joker in the in the
whole program there and
that were you michael were you
anticipating
the icons of and the other
you know characters that look like him
showing up or was that a surprise yeah
well it was a total surprise i i you
know he'd never bought uh or owned any
of our stock in the past and uh you know
maybe i should have anticipated it but
totally totally missed that one um and
you know it it was the biggest uh
go private ever for uh a tech technology
company
at the time and
you know what we did was give the
shareholders
some of the benefit of our
uh transformation if it was successful
without taking any of the risk
and uh so shareholders got you know a
big premium and
uh we took on all the risk and we went
for it and we you know we started
super aggressively hiring more r d
engineers and introducing tons of
innovation
uh hiring thousands of additions
where were you where were you in your
life at this point as a as a
professional filter where how what were
you active in
before this maneuver
i was the ceo of the company so got it
so you went from public ceo i'm sorry
but i wanted to make sure i had that
context and everybody listen so you were
the public ceo
but because of the lack of permission
for pricing the stock you decided to
take it private
yeah basically that's right i mean you
know we we um had had a period of of
great success
but you know things started to change in
the late 2000s and we started to
go in all these new areas and as i said
kind of the more we
uh were rebuilding and transforming the
company the less the market liked it and
ultimately at that point in time
being
public was rate limiting for our
transformation and so i felt that
wow you know we could really accelerate
this
if we weren't thinking about uh earning
every 90 days right and michael was the
company structured in a way this is
where i want to get people educated
where
because you went public in a very
different day than some of the companies
that have gone public in the last decade
you as a ceo and the founder of it
at that point
what i love what you're man it makes me
admire you so much i i have such
lack of interest to ever do anything
public because i'm incredibly scared of
being held accountable every 90 days
to something because then you can never
do what you need to do for the consumer
because you're just milking your p l for
profit
you were in a position as a public ceo
that if you made the statement like hey
world
i'm going to do what's right for us in
three years from now
that they might the board might have
been able to get rid of you and you
wouldn't have been able to see it
through which then forced you to have to
take it private to be able to do what
you wanted to do with your company
well so um
maybe yes and no so you're not yet
earlier in 2012 uh the shareholders
re-elected me to be uh you know uh uh
chairman of the board with 96 of the
vote so you know got it so that wasn't
the case you just so it was it was less
i'm sorry to throw up it was less that
you
might have not seen it through because
people would have been upset that it
wouldn't have been performing as well in
the short term for long term it was more
that you actually just saw how big the
business opportunity was
and so you decided to go about it that
way
yeah the the the silver lining in
the market kind of not understanding the
transformation that we were on
and not understanding
that you know the smartphone was not
going to
uh destroy the pc that was more of an
end thing
created this incredible opportunity to
accelerate the transformation and so
uh you know we we went through that and
you know within 18 months after we had
done the the take private
our net debt was basically zero so we
just were paying down debt at a
ferociously fast rate
and then we we decided to kind of
quadruple down and do the biggest merger
acquisition ever in technology with emc
and vmware and create the number one
company in all of cloud infrastructure
and
you know we we thought that would work
well it turned out to work uh far better
than even we imagined
and uh now we're public again we just
got a two notch upgrade back to
investment grade we've paid down tons of
debt and last quarter we grew 15 percent
we had uh 50 billion in revenues in the
first half of the year and
uh you know
michael with that with that insanity of
success
uh
wha what would you say just another day
at the office gary that i know brother
and listen you are truly truly and i i
don't say this lightly
you truly an incredible entrepreneur and
visionary
of the last 40 years and because of your
humility and the way you navigate
just you know one man's point of view
macro underrated um
you know i'm gonna ask you an
interesting question that actually ties
into my new book which talks about
emotional intelligence being a framework
for success and i i don't know you
uh i know
several people pretty well that are
fairly close to you and i've always had
this sense of you so i'm excited that i
got to achieve to ask you this
the first chapter that insanity i'm
going public at 23 years old
the brilliance in my opinion from a
business standpoint of taking a private
to where you are now
betting on the cloud to your point i get
it i lived through those years of like i
understand why you believe that because
it absolutely
worked but it worked incredibly well
what um
from an emotional intelligence
standpoint forget about the business
strategy maybe the consumer lens some of
the different stuff technology chops
which you have
in this last in this book in this
chapter this last decade or two through
15 years
what emotional intelligence
are you most proud of or you think was
most significant
for you to navigate it was it empathy
was it compassion was it accountability
was it patience like if i asked you the
soft you know i'm on a
binge right now to try to educate a lot
of people that the soft skills are
actually the hard skills
and i again from afar really see a lot
of them in you but don't really have
under the hood so i'm trying to go there
in this latest chapter where the book
picked up and this great chapter of your
career
which which emotional intelligence
or human characteristic skills do you
think and i know you don't love talk
about yourself that way but you can help
a lot of people right now which one over
indexed or you think was foundational or
which couple really mattered during this
chapter
i i think i learned a lot about
empathy and you know
understanding
people's motivations and
i think you know that was that was
helpful to me
um
i think i also
uh upped my game a bit in
in understanding how to
tap into to passion and and to uh really
you know make uh what we're doing as
important as it really is and and uh you
know have people super excited that what
they do matters in the world and
uh you know
that's been that's been pretty powerful
uh but look you know it's all about
how do you
uh
you know create a a winning team of
people enable empower them give them
this exciting vision and um
you know turn
turn them loose you've got to have the
right strategy too right and you've got
to execute
um but you know you
you put those things together and
you you know uh treat people with
respect and fairly and
uh you deliver do you think people do
you think people underestimate kindness
in business they think it's a weakness
given how we've portrayed the business
world sharp elbows win compete do you
think
very point blind question do you think
kindness and business is underrated
well i think there's a long arc to
uh
you know
reputations and
relationships and
you know i can't tell you the number of
times that you know interacted with
somebody and then
uh you know
three years later five years later they
turn up
a completely different company
completely different position
and it's like oh i remember you
you you know you you were you were great
to work with
and
all that comes back to you yes it does
you know uh just dealing with people in
in the right way
i think really matters and
um you know call it play nice play nice
but win
uh something my my parents taught taught
my two brothers and i when we were
little kids and it's kind of kind of
stuck with me
how about candor something i've
struggled with as a public persona
strong on stage my content actually it's
my strength
as a private
you know business leader
it's something i really struggled with
were you naturally good at candor was
that something that you needed to evolve
evolve excuse me is uh
you know i call it kind candor as an
ethos now in the company because i think
candor has often been used as an excuse
to not be nice and it definitely at all
wait many times to the insecure
leads to a lot of fear so i've always
had this interesting relationship with
candor how about your relationship with
candor
well i've always been very you know
forthright
and
and uh candid in that sense but
i was pretty opaque for uh a long time
and and really where that came from was
i did get off to a fast start in life
yeah and um yeah
what happened was a lot of people came
to me and they were asking me for things
right
right made me feel uh
pretty uncomfortable and so
i built a barrier between myself and uh
just about everybody
and
you know that that was kind of limiting
and you know as time has gone on i
figured out other ways to to deal with
that and this book is way more personal
and i think anybody that even people
that know me will be surprised at how
candid what what what what made you
comfortable to go more personal to your
point even where your inner circles like
oh you went a little further is
do feelings about legacy do feelings
about if i give them a little bit more
this may help someone cause it because
going more personal has an incredibly
interesting selfish
selfless framework so i'm dying to hear
what made you feel like you were ready
to go there yeah that's that's the
framework gary and and it's i would say
time and just maturity i mean i did
write a book in the late 90s and it has
very very little of of those you know
kind of uh that you know the the
personal feel
and this this new book has a lot more of
it and i
explained exactly what i was thinking
and feeling
uh during all of those
key
moments and and times and you know while
it might have looked from the outside
like everything was going fantastically
or even in inside in the company you
know people like oh you know
these guys know what they're doing well
it wasn't always that way and i
explained you know everything that that
that was going on the the good the bad
and the ugly
and you know a lot of our mistakes and
uh you know
mess-ups and lessons learned those are
the things that built
the the learning and ultimately created
so much more success later on
michael
at that 19 to 23 year old age group that
19 that's let's call it listen to the
story that 16 to 23 year old michael did
you have a business idol was there
anybody you looked up to
you know i i grew up um
hearing stories and reading stories
about
uh you know charles schwab and ted
turner and
william mcgowan
you know who created mci
and and then of course uh you know bill
gates and steve jobs who were you know
10 years older than than i am
and you know all that excited me the the
the entrepreneurs of of of that time
that were
creating new things and disrupting you
know big businesses
uh you know those those those were my
heroes
and what about now are you
too busy
and have too many focuses and interests
family professionally
or do you like the game of
entrepreneurship enough
that you have a sense of some of the
up-and-comers i'm sure many of which
have probably tried to reach out or have
reached out or have spent time with you
do you have a sense of
the new crop do you get curious about
the new crop or is or is like
is that not where you would spend your
attention
yeah no i i love that i do get to spend
some time on that um you know uh
look i think what's inspiring right now
is there
are so many uh entrepreneurs right and
there is so much risk capital that's
going after
a lot of really hard problems
and
you know that's super exciting i
invested a number of those uh you know
certainly through our company but also
through
uh msd
capital and msd partners
and uh get get to spend time with with
with some of those new entrepreneurs
that are that are building incredible
businesses and that's that you know
that's a ton of fun
what have we not let's wrap this up what
have we not touched on
that you want to make sure i mean one
thing i love about my audience is
they um
they they know that i have trouble
reading and that's not how i consume my
content per se but they have an audio
book for just for you gary did you you
didn't read it did you i did i read the
whole thing i am so proud of you michael
i'll tell you that's [ __ ] good for
you
it's it's it's 10 hours and 30. oh i
just finished mine it's the
it was the hardest thing i ever did yeah
i know man i know it's like emotionally
draining
it's hard training it's hard good for
you
prepared for this yeah you thought it
was going to be appropriate yeah
i i just thought i'd try to read this
thing and i'll be done no it's hard
it's hard
it's hard not to be a robot i don't know
if you ad libbed i get very off script
you know so good for you i'm really
proud of you because it is a time suck
uh so first of all now i know a lot of
people are going to go that route but
i this is a reading crew a lot of people
that's why i keep writing books so many
people consume and learn from them
what did we not touch on because i know
i bounced you around a lot i have a
little specific style that we want to
end with of what people can expect from
this great book
yeah look i think a lot of human
potential is is left on the table
because people are
uh too afraid to fail and don't want to
take risks and
you know uh my my life was a great
example of uh of taking some risks and
and um you know uh
i wouldn't wouldn't advise
everybody to drop out of college but but
uh
you know uh there's there's it seems a
lot more practical today than it was in
your in your era it was
insanity
in 2021 it's there's a lot more practice
yeah
i don't think you agree with that right
michael say again do you agree that
there's a lot more quote-unquote
practicality and opportunity now for
that not to be the path whereas in
comparison
the path of the 80s was very clear it's
a little more blurry now does your does
your degree actually get you an roi
positive situation the the modern you
know the mature internet with an
emerging blockchain has so much
opportunity it it it feels less crazy
and feels a little bit more to be honest
practical against the ideology of
college today
than it did let's say 30 40 years ago
well i don't think you know it's great
generic advice to
uh give up the opportunity to to to
improve your skills right let's put it
that way and
i do think
more and more
um
opportunities are skills based instead
of degree based
and uh you know that's right uh
you know that's that's kind of that's
kind of my thought yeah i think that's
exactly right nonetheless what uh let's
wrap this up will any any part of the
book that we didn't touch on that might
be good
you know i think we we we covered it uh
we covered it pretty well i i do i do go
uh really all throughout you know the
not only 37 years of the company but my
my childhood and uh hope people draw
some great lessons from it and uh
it was it was a lot of fun it was a lot
of fun writing it and it was really hard
to uh to do the audiobook
it's a fun way to end michael listen
i'm glad i did it
i'm glad you did it too brother i think
it speaks to your authenticity i'm
really
i'm really glad we got to do this i
really appreciate your time i'm cheering
for you i hope everybody in the vayner
nation picks up a copy of the book uh i
think this is one of the true underrated
operators of the last half century
and
and i wish you nothing but health and
happiness my man
thank you so much gary great to be with
you
youtube watcher what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times
i also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you